during a joint address with secretary of
state anthony blinken on human
trafficking kamala harris articulated
her theory of which groups should be
considered the most vulnerable
we are focused on the most vulnerable
and based on my experience the most
vulnerable
are women and girls
racial and ethnic minorities
lgbtqi plus people
indigenous people
people with disabilities
migrants
and children in the foster care system
when we identify who is most vulnerable
we can tailor our tactics and improve
our strategy
so according to kamala harris
every single person on the face of the
earth is vulnerable to human trafficking
except for
me i am the only one
it's not straight white dudes who know
that they are dudes are
according to kamala harris and the rest
of the liberal establishment by the way
the only
non-vulnerable group
on earth
which got me thinking
when every power structure in the
country says that only one group is
invulnerable and therefore unworthy of
protection
doesn't that make
that group
the most vulnerable group i'm ostensibly
male definitely straight and arguably
white and this is the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from stray dog
who says a few hundred years ago tom
hanks would be the guy wearing a funny
hat while juggling to entertain the king
a few hundred years ago i
i agree with your comment except for
that few hundred years ago point tom
hanks and all of hollywood are still
doing the same role that they would have
been doing 200 years ago 300 years ago a
thousand years ago they are the jesters
in the court they serve the power
they serve at the pleasure of the king
and when the king calls in a favor and
says hey tom hanks make me a commercial
that makes me look good you know that
that jester is going to dance that's
just the way it works and biden needs it
right now because among other problems
gas is going through the roof which is
why you need to check out get upside how
would you feel if you could get 25 cents
back per gallon every time you go to the
pump you'd probably feel pretty good
about that what if i told you that for
your first fill up you could actually
get 50 cents per gallon cash back you'd
probably feel even better about that
what if i told you that you could do all
of this for free with the free get
upside app that's right get the free get
upside app
enter code knowles kowles you will save
up to 50 cents per gallon
uh for your first fill up and then
you'll save 25 cents per gallon for
every fill up after that there's no
catch just cash back the cash gets added
directly to your bank account or it can
go to paypal if you prefer or it can go
to an amazon gift card or a gift card to
some other shop it is super easy people
who drive a lot are saving two to three
hundred bucks per year with get upside
download the free get upside app use
promo code knowles to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
that is
k-o-w-l-e-s knowles
l
code
it is not just straight white men
who know that they are men who are
catching the brunt of woke politics
these days
although we are being insulted
and
and uh
discriminated against and
maligned by all the people in power
but it's not just
those white dudes it's also black guys
who have the audacity to buck the
prevailing political orthodoxies there
is an incredible video going around of a
a black guy in an elevator who is
standing next to a couple of
white women of a certain age and he's
not wearing his mask because he's not
brainwashed he's not hypnotized he knows
that
there's more to life than masking
yourself up like a bandito to avoid a
cough and so he's in there and these
women start screaming at him and hitting
him actually all while yelling black
lives matter
get out yeah you should go step up get
out get out what are you guys doing
what are you guys doing
get
get out of here you dirty filthy black
man get out of here with your filthy
dirty germs you cannot be in here with
us clean clean white ladies black lives
matter
black lives totally matte i don't know
what sort of accent they have some
european accent i take it
and the guy seems to be getting kind of
a kick at it he's like hey man stop
hitting me what are you i'm not getting
out of the elevator come on i'm just i'm
just trying to get up to my floor
they're like no no these are hitting him
black lives matter how do they do this
how do they resolve this
that they are claiming black lives
matter as they are
literally
attacking a black guy and trying to get
him off of the elevator
it makes perfect sense
under wokeness under political
correctness under cultural liberalism
would you call it whatever you want
saying the right thing
supplants doing the right thing
this has always been the case
so
the actions that these women are
engaging in are
quite
ugly cruel uncharitable
discriminatory even but what they're
saying
is we are good people right that's what
when you say blm these days you're just
saying we are good people we're good
we're not bad we're good and so they're
saying we are good people even as
they're doing a very bad thing
that is how wokism works this is why
corporations
well they're doing all sorts of bad
things
on labor while they're doing all sorts
of bad things politically while they're
doing all sorts of bad things even on
the environment in some cases they will
say the right thing they'll wave the
rainbow flag they'll post the black
square on blm day and then they think
that gets them off the hook these
hollywood celebrities flying around in
private jets spewing pollution into the
atmosphere
well it's fine they get off the hook for
that because they say
that they're supporting
climate efforts they're climate fighters
they're not climate deniers
all of these rich white celebrities who
live in extremely rich white
neighborhoods and send their kids to
really rich white schools
they say black lives matter and so they
they have no
racial animus they have no
no race problems
poor white people who are friends with
black people who live in communities
with black people who send their kids to
schools with black people if they don't
say blm if they don't support anarchists
and rioters in the streets well they're
dirty rotten racists
saying the right thing supplants
doing the right thing
now
these these white women i i hate to
discriminate but these white women in
particular can sometimes be guilty of
this especially on the view so one of
the cackling hens on the view
who seems to be
a member of this certain species of
upper class white women
liberal upper class white women she
articulated her extraordinarily neurotic
view
that life can never go back to normal
after covid
i think there's a prudence we've learned
with the mass the hand sanitate
hand sanitizing that kind of like 911
with flying is always going to be here
now there's a new normal in the
beginning when at post 911 people didn't
want to fly and the security measures
felt like uh how do we do this you know
and now it's the norm i think some of
the things we've learned in this
pandemic are going to stay the same i
may never write a subway again without a
mask i may never go indoors to big
crowds and never feel comfortable
without a mask and that's up to me to do
that
obviously this is insane behavior and an
insane way of viewing the world that you
will never
see people again you will never go into
a large group of people without
covering up your face
so you'll never you'll never see a group
full of smiles again that's gone you
will never share air with a group of
people again you will never take public
transportation again without wearing a
secular hijab but kefia
that's insane behavior
but even beyond that she says look and
if you want to do that that's up to you
i don't think that should be up to you
right now the debate on the masks is
over two positions there's the leftist
position which is every single person
needs to wear at least one or two masks
and then there's the kind of
conservative position
which is that if you want to wear a mask
do it and if you don't want to wear a
mask don't
that's kind of the squish position
i'd like to suggest a further position a
genuinely conservative position which is
you should not be permitted
outside of very rare exceptions very
rare circumstances you should not be
permitted to wear a mask in public
we do not want to be a society of
banditos that is disordered it's weird
we look like we're train robbers in the
wild west
it is not serving the medical function
that we were told it would after we were
told it would not after we were told it
would you know obviously it's gone back
and forth quite a lot because the public
health establishment is extremely
cynical and dishonest and deceptive
but we should not permit it i don't i do
not want to live in a society where
we're all covering up each other's faces
if you want to move to afghanistan if
you want to that's fine go go i don't
care if the women on the view want to
move to afghanistan i'm not going to
stop them but i don't want to live in
that society and i have some rights to
decide
how this society is going to function
because i'm a citizen because i'm a
member of that society and i think there
are a whole lot of us who don't want to
live in this sterile world where we no
longer view our countrymen as our
brothers as our kinsfolk where we just
view them as walking bags of germs who
are going to kill us all i'm not i'm out
i don't want that okay and so in as much
as i have any political power i am going
to stop
i'm on a mission of mercy i'm going to
stop these neurotic women on the view
from driving themselves even crazier
than they already are okay
take off the stupid masks they're really
dumb they're i'm not by the way
by the way youtube
by the way facebook by the way big tech
i'm not making any medical claim here
i'm not making any claim about the
transmissibility and the how it affects
i'm not i'm making a political claim the
masks are dumb i hate them they're
disordered people should not use that
it's degrading take them off
okay that's my claim can't fact check me
on that it's obviously true
they want to lock us all in our pods so
when it comes to reality
the left is trying to isolate us all
from one another
socially physically they're going to try
to put us all in our pods and then they
want us all to reconnect
in a dystopian future
virtual reality
now when you want to hear lots of
interesting things about what happened
in the past what might happen in the
future i would recommend you tune into
the jordan arbinger show it's about time
you check out the jordan harbinger show
a top shelf podcast named best of apple
in 2018 jordan dives into the minds of
fascinating people from athletes to
authors to scientists to mobsters to
spies check out his episode with jack
schaefer or kobe bryant without fail
harbinger pulls out tactical bits of
wisdom in each episode all with the
noble cause to make you a more informed
critical thinker to better operate in
today's world he's also got a strangely
relatable weekly segment called feedback
friday where jordan covers advice on
everything from psycho family situations
to relationships to networking you can't
go wrong with adding the jordan
harbinger show to your rotation it's
incredibly interesting there's never a
dull show search for the jordan
harbinger show that's h-a-r-b as in boy
i-n as in nancy g-e-r as in really go do
it right now on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcasts
that is the jordan harbinger show enjoy
the
the ladies on the view think that we
should all just lock ourselves in our
rooms forever
now this sounds kind of depressing
except there's really good news
because the rest of the liberal
establishment moving from the corporate
press into big tech right now they have
a way that we're all going to really
enjoy ourselves they're going to plug us
into the metaverse facebook just
unrolled their new product
this is
the first step toward just plugging all
of our brain stems into the matrix this
is the facebook horizon product that is
going to revolutionize the way that we
live
beyond our world
there's another world
and it's right here
on my face
welcome this is horizon think of me as
your guide self-appointed spokes avatar
here to show you around you know horizon
is filled with possibilities he can play
stuff make stuff fly stuff wow i really
love the stash stuart
what up stuart wait i want a mustache
horizon isn't about rules or limits or
pants
or people telling you not to fly an
airplane while drinking your fresh
ground fair trade french press morning
coffee through a curly straw isn't that
right debbie
it's about getting out there and trying
new things making your mark
making friends with an australian named
mark oh actually i'm from new zealand
and you can even build a world of your
own like laser tag moon landing
[Music]
we just need to get out there you know
just come on facebook horizon it's about
getting out there by locking yourself in
your room and putting on goggles so you
can't even see the small world around
you
you know
you know out there
meaning in there meaning the meaning the
opposite of out there
the creepiest thing about this video for
those of you who are just listening and
didn't get to see it
is that no one has any legs
they're all just floating around in
their
blazers
and there's just air between their
bottom of their stomach
and the ground
and that was the joke that they
referenced they said you don't even need
to worry about pants i thought why why
don't this how did they take this
already creepy thing why would they make
it so much creepier and then it occurred
to me oh it's because of all the sex
stuff
it's because if people had legs in this
virtual reality world they would all
just be
screwing around the whole time
it actually that's not even just my
speculation that already happened in one
of these beta tests on the virtual
reality some woman claimed that she was
sexually groped
in the metaverse she obviously was not
sexually groped because she was sitting
in her pod alone in her room no one
touched her body
but they touched the representation of
her body and so i guarantee you this was
the thinking on this
they said gosh
if we have legs and all the stuff
between the legs and the belly you know
then this is going to get this is going
to go downhill real fast because the
whole premise of virtual reality is
there are no rules any of your appetites
you can satisfy and one of the main
appetites that human beings have is the
sexual appetite so they say okay we're
just going to denude
we're going to we're going to take away
the
sexual aspect of man
one of the
if not the central part of our physical
nature we're just going to take that
away
and now you're all going to float around
this is a regression back into childhood
that you're seeing first of all by
unsexing people that's a regression back
into childhood you're going back to a
prepubescent state
through the
decision to live in a cartoon world
right we're gonna we're gonna take
ourselves out of the real world we're
gonna put ourselves back into a cartoon
world with magical castles where we can
dance on the moon where we can go on
roller coasters and fly airplanes while
sipping through a sippy straw through a
curly straw isn't that so wonderful
at a time when the world needs
many more adults we don't have our
adults are not acting like adults
already
what virtual reality is offering us is
an even more radical regression into
childhood
and ultimately what this is
is an attack on the physical this is
something that the the conservatives
have not understood about the way the
left is operating right now
the left one of the
chief instruments by which the left is
reordering our culture
is by attacking the physical world i'll
give you an example of this the bbc
right now just came out the bbc british
broadcasting company
they are censoring their own
media their own content their own tv
shows
the daily telegraph just reported that
an anonymous radio 4 extra listener had
quote discovered the bbc had been
quietly editing repeats of shows over
the past few years to keep more in
keeping with social mores
so now now we're finding out that the
entrenched powers they're not just
censoring
experience like you see in the metaverse
in the facebook horizon they're
censoring art culture history pretty
radical claim pretty serious accusation
what say you bbc
they admitted it
the bbc said quote on occasion we edit
some episodes so they are suitable for
broadcast today including removing
racially offensive language and
stereotypes from decades ago as the vast
majority of our audience would expect
you know i hate to say i told you so i
have seen this coming
many of you have as well
for many months if not years now
i have stopped
buying digital
books digital movies i'll still buy them
on occasion when i especially when i
need them very quickly but in terms of
my collections of media
i really only buy physical now
i buy physical books when i can i try to
buy physical movies even physical
photographs
because
when
when all of your media are digital
then they are open to surreptitious
editing you don't really own them even
when you when you download a movie and
you think you own that movie you don't
you've bought a license for that movie
but netflix or amazon or whoever is
distributing that movie they can take it
away whenever they want or they can edit
that movie whenever they want
the big
the big misconception here
is that we primarily think of the libs
as trying to change our culture
by disconnecting us from the spiritual
right the the libs are trying to take us
out of church the libs are trying to
stop us from praying no prayer in
schools no bible in schools the libs are
trying to mock the idea that there is a
god or a transcendent moral order the
the libs are pushing materialism say
they're saying we're just flesh and
blood
when they're not pushing
the opposite of materialism when they
say that our bodies have nothing to do
with who we are with transgenderism
right it's an attack on the spiritual we
think no
not primarily primarily it's an attack
on the physical if they can divorce us
from the physical world
and our natural physical connections
then
then it's much more more easy for them
to upend our spiritual understanding too
i know this is a little bit pie in the
sky
so look at it in really tangible terms
we come into this world what is our
dearest physical connection
what is what is the dearest physical
thing about us it's probably our sex
right the physical differences between
little boys and little girls so what
does the left do they deny that and you
see this
in the theory of transgenderism what's
our next nearest physical connection
it's to mommy and daddy the connection
between a
little baby and his mother is the
nearest physical connection he's going
to have so they try to divorce that no
longer does a baby need a mommy now a
baby can be made in a test tube and be
given to a mommy and a daddy or just a
mommy or just a daddy or two daddies or
three daddies and a goat doesn't matter
they're they're disconnecting
reproduction from the natural sexual act
beyond that then the nearest physical
connection we have is from a little
child to our families
the left is trying to get rid of that as
quickly as they possibly can
they want the child taken away from the
family earlier and earlier not just in
first grade but then in kindergarten not
just in kindergarten but then in
preschool not just in preschool but
starting when you're two or three years
old the state will fund this they will
take they'll pay you
to take your kid away and
and instruct this child
and raise that child and educate him
and then they'll stay in college longer
and longer and longer and then you will
be impelled
to move away from your family don't stay
in your hometown move away move away we
all do it so many of us do it these days
move to a city move have every break
that physical connection
and then we'll be told don't when you
even when you go to work don't go to
work you don't need to go to work
anymore
go you don't need to go into an office
just zoom in
just sit in your pod and open up your
computer
and
communicate digitally
won't that be fun
this is what the the world economic
forum has talked about this is what
so many of our international elite
institutions have talked about
you hear phrases like the great reset
your phrases like you you will own
nothing and you will be happy you won't
even have ownership of your body
you won't even have that connection to
your body forget ownership you don't
even have that connection they're trying
to sever you
james pulas at the claremont institute
made this great point he said
transgenderism
it's a little bit of a distraction it's
a way to get into transhumanism don't do
it grab on have real physical
connections acknowledge physical reality
boys girls family country culture
borders stop denying the physical
world
you know the next episode of adam
corolla's comedy series truth yeller
airs tomorrow
adam is joined by silicon valley actor
and comedian tj miller who wears a very
short clip on time and takes no
prisoners check it out
sorry i was i was just jogging i was
trying to find my dog
but i double fisted because you know it
evens out as you jog the weight this guy
looked at me and he goes it's true it is
true
i'm joking but you're serious this guy
really does
do it hi hey thank you for having me
thanks for coming out oh i'm excited
this is just a prop though do you want
this
oh you won't take it huh why coven you
one of those guys huh
won't drink a stranger's beer because
the covenant
i i i hate those guys i know i agree
come on let's just spread a little germs
get your immune system up head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe use code
miller m-i-l-l-e-r for 25 off your
membership look out for the new episode
with tj miller dropping tomorrow also
daily wire now has our own publishing
wing you know that it's dw books we're
very proud to be publishing two books
that are actively fighting the left's
monopoly on storytelling the first is 12
seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly the book is the true story of
what really happened the night of the
brianna taylor shooting from the 20-year
police veteran and the second is fiery
but mostly peaceful by julio roses who
pulls back the curtain and sets the
record straight on the black lives
matter riots that broke out across the
country in 2020. i can't wait for you to
hear their stories both are available
for pre-order now on amazon or anywhere
you buy books online we'll be right back
with a lot more
this attack this liberal attack on
physical stuff real tangible physical
stuff
goes really really deep it's not even
just about your personal life it's not
even just about your home or your family
goes to the national borders
traditionally we think of a nation as
being the place within the nation's
borders the nation is having something
to do with the people of that nation
what the left tells us is no there's no
such thing as the borders don't matter
borders are
are either fake or evil or both
either way we need to ignore them the
people of a country that doesn't really
matter some guy in timbuktu is more
american than joe blow in
in mississippi why i don't know how is
that pot what does that mean it doesn't
mean anything
but it it
it is
why are we now not permitted to use
physical money you'll notice
increasingly we are discouraged from
using physical money we're supposed to
use electronic money much easier for a
centralized power to freeze your
electronic money if it's just numbers on
a spreadsheet rather than physical money
even physical money just fiat money is
less real than say money backed by a a
tangible good like like gold for
instance
this can go much much much deeper it's
not just something that was decided over
the past couple of years by the world
economic forum or something like that
and this is why
all of that is to say
i really liked a comment that jen saki
made the other day and she was pilloried
for this comment by the left
and by the right and i need to stand up
and defend jen because i found the
comment charming and actually somewhat
encouraging
my advice to everyone out there who's
frustrated sad angry pissed off feel
those emotions go to a kickboxing class
have a margarita do whatever you need to
do this weekend and then wake up on
monday morning we gotta keep fighting
and what that means lindsay is we have
to keep talking to members about federal
legislation that's essential that's
something that can be permanent that can
make sure people's rights are protected
but we also need to uh make sure people
are educated in states across the
country about what their rights are uh
how they can vote when they can vote how
to request an absentee ballot there's a
lot we need to do on that front and
that's going to rely on the energy and
the anger of those that activism as well
i love this
of course the second half is just blah
blah blah be a democrat help the
democrat talking points sure that's what
you expect that's her job she's a
spokesman for the democrat president
that first part
look you're angry you're pissed off
hey guys
go to a kickboxing class go outside go
see your friends go get a drink at the
bar go have a margarita cool it there's
more to life than just these
specific policy battles there's more
there's your friends there's your
community there's the local bar down the
street and there's the gym on the other
end of the street go do that and then
you can get back to work on monday
beautiful
thank you
thank you
great advice first of all there is more
to life
than these specific policy battles of
course
but
second
going into our communities
actually just talking to friends
can be extraordinarily restorative
jordan peterson had a comment the other
day that i thought was so
good
i don't think he's the first person to
come up with this idea but he
articulated it in a really clear way
which is that rationality is a communal
endeavor
when you are alone
for long periods of time
you go crazy
inevitably
this is also as an important lesson for
the radical individualists on the right
the radical individualism says leave me
alone i'm gonna go sit alone on my farm
in montana my ranch in montana i'm gonna
have a mini gun ready to just blast away
anybody who comes near me
i am an individual i am an island i'm an
atomized person floating in space no
you're crazy if you think that you're
crazy i know
that some right wingers feel pushed to
take that position because the left is
trying to bundle us all together in a
commie collective
but you are not an individual and the
opposite of communism or socialism is
not individualism they're actually two
sides of the same coin what the left has
always done is broken down society into
a group of atomized individuals broken
down all those institutions all the
mediating institutions notably the
family then once you're all a bunch of
individuals they bundle you all together
the fascists bundle you all together in
a
bag of sticks
not a bag a bundle of sticks rather
my fascist image imagery escaped me for
a second and the socialists bundle you
all together underneath the the
edges of the state
and they just bundle you all together
and they treat you as little little dots
little inputs in a spreadsheet rather
than as real people with real
communities with real institutions and
what jen saki is saying is no come on
just go out there
get out there in the physical world see
your friends it's a good thing it'll
keep it'll keep you much more rational
part of the reason people have lost
their freaking minds over the past two
years is because we have isolated
ourselves we have not been in community
we have been sitting alone a lot of
people have been sitting alone for two
years and that will inevitably drive you
nuts now
that is the only sensible thing
that gensake has said recently saki was
just asked yesterday about the decision
of the fda to prevent certain states
notably florida from receiving
monoclonal antibodies this is a
treatment that seemed to show
a great success in dealing with kovid
now they've cut cut off florida ronda
santos is furious about this here's
sake's response the fda yesterday
withdrew the eua for some
monoclonal antibody treatments because
they don't work against omicron
but florida continues to push for the
treatment for people in the state
what's your response to governor santis
and what's your message to the people of
florida
well let's just take a step back here
just to realize how crazy this is a
little bit um we've approached uh covert
treatments like filling a medicine
cabinet we're not relying on one type
one brand or treatment we invested in
and continue to buy a variety across
monoclonal antibodies
pre-exposure prevention therapies and
oral antivirals we have provided 71 000
doses of antivirals to florida including
34 000 additional treatments that do
work against omicron just this last week
i'm sorry about of a range of those
treatments i should say to be clear what
the fda is making clear is that these
treatments the ones that they are
fighting over that the governor is
fighting over do not work against
omicron and they have side effects that
is what the scientists are saying we
have sent them 271 000 doses of
treatments that are effective against
omicron
think about how insane this is
the fda the spokesman for science said
something
and and then the governor in florida
he's he's disagreeing with that how
insane is that
as if ron desantis doesn't have health
advisors in florida as if it's just
ron desantis on some message board
online you know passing around
conspiracy theories
contradicting the geniuses at the fda no
i'm pretty sure ron desantis has pretty
good health advisors in florida i forget
the health sector his name in florida he
appointed him not not too long ago
extraordinarily impressive guy but he
had
a different take on covid and on the
mandates and on the lockdowns and on the
vaccines and on the treatments then the
feds did than the
democrat
health advisors
at the national level
this is not a battle between the
scientists on one hand and ron desantis
and the politicians on the other
this is two battles that overlap
a battle between the feds and the states
and a battle between the democrats and
the republicans the democrats control
the federal government
usually and especially right now ron
desantis and the republicans control the
state
which do you think has a better record
if you had to say right now okay i'm
getting two different contradictory
pieces of medical advice one from the
federal government and the democrats and
joe biden
and one from ron desantis
and the conservatives and the states who
do you think has a better record on
kovid
it's obviously desantis
it's obviously the republicans it's
obviously florida
way better record than joe biden
all i know about the fda
and the fba here is a representative of
the broader public health establishment
of dr fauci and dr scarf and rachelle
wolenski and the rest of them
they've gotten
most things wrong about covid
i don't think that's an exaggeration
they've gotten most things wrong and in
some cases they've lied
so
i think i'm going to go with desantis i
think i'm going to go with his health
advisors i think i'm going to go with
the states and the republicans that's
just the rational thing to do if you
want to follow the science that would be
the logical conclusion
meanwhile meanwhile the idea that the
liberal
health establishment is is really
engaging in open discourse and following
the science is that that silly notion is
collapsing all around us there was
senate testimony just just the other day
from dr aaron cariarty
explaining how at least in the state of
california
there is no opportunity to dissent from
the politically correct
orthodoxy on these issues that actually
even when you think there's an
opportunity to dissent really the
entrenched powers that be are going to
go in and and cut that off at the knees
went out to all physicians
from the medical board saying any
physician in california who writes an
inappropriate exemption
for masks or other covet related
measures
will have his medical license subjected
to
investigation and disciplinary action
so for a physician just to help you to
understand
this kind of
uh threat hanging over your head is
worse than the threat of getting fired
if i get fired from a particular
healthcare organization i can go to
another health corps organization or go
start a private practice if i lose
my medical license i cannot practice
medicine
okay that's how serious this is the
letter never defined what might
constitute an appropriate or
inappropriate mask mandate so i have no
idea if i write a mandate for a kid with
a severe anxiety disorder that's
worsened by the wearing of a mask is
that is that going to subject my medical
license to disciplinary action
it has become de facto impossible to get
a medical exemption for a covet vaccine
in the state of california
it has become de facto so not maybe not
according to the letter of the law but
in practice in fact it has become
impossible to get those exemptions
why because the doctors you're told if
you give the exemption
then
you're very likely going to lose your
license and so the doctors are not going
to do it
there are plenty of good reasons
not to get the vaccine
i'm not saying that there are no good
reasons to get the vaccine necessarily
i'm saying that there are plenty of good
reasons not to get the vaccine there are
the moral considerations
namely all of the vaccines are produced
at least produced and some are developed
with
rather they're all developed with some
are produced with fetal stem cells cells
derive from these these fetal stem cell
lines
and
there are there are medical reasons not
to get the vaccines there have been
a number of studies that have shown
risks of side effects including
inflammation of the heart including
nerve damage including
blood clotting and including death
not saying it's common it's more
pronounced
risk in certain groups than other groups
and so you could make a prudential
judgment huh not really so much at risk
from the virus so maybe i'm going to
avoid the vex there are plenty of
reasons
not to particularly if you have some
heart condition right
particularly if you have moral qualms
about it
and it's almost impossible to get those
exemptions
so the liberal establishment gets to
pretend that yeah listen we're just
we're just following the science we're
we're being very open-minded we're
granting exemptions but by the way if
you don't go along with exactly what
we're saying right this very second even
if it contradicts what we said two
seconds ago if you don't do that right
now we're going to destroy your life
we're going to destroy your career
but you have choice it's not choice it's
the illusion of choice and this is
having real world effects by the way
these sorts of ideas are having real
world effects there is a 31 year old
father right now
who is waiting for a heart transplant
over at a boston hospital
and he's right up toward the top of the
list
and he is reportedly
being bumped off that list
why is he being bumped off of that list
or being bumped way way down the list
you know you can
intuit what i'm going to say
it's because he refuses to take the
covid vaccine
so a man
is very very likely very possibly
probably very likely going to die
because he refuses to take the vaccine
without which the public health
establishment says
he is going to die
and he's got a good reason to avoid the
vaccine too
31 year old father currently at a boston
hospital
refusing to get the vaccine his name is
dj ferguson his family says he was the
first on the list to receive a
transplant at brigham and women's
hospital but he's no longer eligible
because of his vaccine status this
according to cbs boston
now his father says i think my boy is
fighting pretty damn courageously and he
has integrity and principles he he
believes in and that makes me respect
him all the more it's his body it's his
choice okay
why won't he get the vaccine you would
think look you're 31 year old guy you
got a couple of kids you got another kid
on the way
you're up on the list for the heart
transplant just get the vaccine right
what's the worst that happens you die
well you're going to die anyway very
likely so i
i see
why people would say just go just get it
now maybe he's got some moral
convictions about it he says i'm not
going to use i'm not going to even
engage in the remote cooperation with
evil that that is entailed in taking
these vaccines because of the fetal body
parts
fetal stem cells
maybe i'm not sure that that's his
motivation here either
his argument is that he's got a very
serious heart condition and that the
vaccines have caused inflammation of the
heart in young men and so he could end
up taking the vaccine and then dying
shortly thereafter and according to this
report the doctors have said as much the
doctors have said yeah
there's a chance might not be a huge
chance but there's a there's a chance
that you get this vaccine and then your
heart just
explodes basically
and it enlarges so much and there's no
more room for it to enlarge that you
could
you could die from the vaccine that's a
risk
so he's saying well i don't want to do
that let's see if i can go to a
different hospital let's see if there's
some different rule and he's being
caught in this madness
the issue is more complex than some
conservatives make it out to be
but obviously there are legit reasons
not to get this vaccine the only issue
here that i
push back against is
the my body my choice argument
this guy should get this guy should
totally
be allowed to stay on the list for the
heart transplant this guy is doing
nothing wrong this guy has plenty of
good reasons not to get the vaccine
but that's not a general rule
the my my body my choice
is a leftist slogan to defend abortion
and i'm all for conservatives throwing
that slogan back in their face to own
the libs because now the libs are trying
to force us all to inject ourselves with
the fouchy algae and they're clearly
hypocrites
but we don't actually believe it guys we
don't
my body my choice is not our slogan
that's their slogan it's a dumb slogan
so
i don't think conservatives should be
adopting that
there are plenty of laws in our society
that we conservatives support
that impede some bodily autonomy
laws against
using drugs that would be the clearest
example
unless you're willing to make at least
unless you're willing during the most
deadly
drug opioid epidemic ever in our
nation's history unless you're willing
to make heroin and fentanyl illegal
then you support some drug laws
meaning you don't believe my body my
choice
unless you oppose public indecency laws
and you think that people ought to be
able to strut down the sidewalk in their
birthday suit
then you support
some
incursions into bodily autonomy you
don't support my body my choice
the leftist view and the radical
individualist view
is that you should be able to do
whatever you want with your body that's
not the conservative you we are not
anarchists we we believe if we believe
anything at all we believe that there is
a transcendent moral order we believe
that tradition matters we believe that
reverence and humility and respect
matter
and so no you can't just do whatever you
want with your body
this is causing a big problem right now
for trump
because trump is launching ostensibly
launching this new social network called
truth social and truth social has just
announced that they will have content
moderation
and so now it's being attacked as not
being a total free speech platform
truth social announced
this according to devin nunes the former
congressman who's now running truth
social
we want to be very family friendly we
want this to be a very safe place and we
are focused on making sure any illegal
content is not on the site
we're going to limit sexually explicit
content and posts that include violence
bullying hate speech and spam
some more individualist types are really
pushing back against this
but
this is good actually this is good
moderation is good
moderation is not a vice moderation is a
virtue it's one of the four cardinal
virtues temperance we like moderation we
don't want there to be all sorts of
disgusting illegal filthy terrible
things
you're you're seeing conservatives begin
to recognize this in the curriculum
debate because the curriculum debate
over crt and schools and creepy lgbt
lmnop pornography in schools the the
conservative position now is not
well hey
we should have some straight material in
there too hey let's put some straight
porn in the libraries too
okay i would never say we should
moderate or ban anything from our
curricula or our libraries
but i'm just saying if we're going to
have
anti-white racism we should have some
pro-weight racism too right is that what
no we're not saying that
we're saying
take out
the bad stuff
take out the poison it is not good in
our education in our society there are
plenty of things we don't like this is
not an assault on free speech this is
the defense of free speech
because free speech always requires
limits otherwise
free speech can be abused
into cacophony otherwise liberty can be
abused into licentiousness which our
founding fathers told us is a really
really bad
idea
sp before i go i got to get to this this
is really quick
speaking of speech that should be
censored brian stelter brian stelter at
cnn 2018
he tweeted out emphatically calling a
journalist an sob it was wrong when
trump was a candidate it's even worse
now that he's president these threats
expose journalists to threats and
intimidation
and then joe biden does the exact same
thing and brian stelter apparently gets
a kick out of it and he's retweeting
some defenses of it and then
then he says okay this is 2018. it's
still true yeah okay it's not so great
still out of line but the context is
different
because it's no longer trump yeah that's
true i actually think brian stelter
makes a good point here
it is different when democrats go after
the press because democrats in the press
are on the same side with very few
exceptions it actually is different it's
not just pure hypocrisy it is to quote
the law professor adrian vermuel
hierarchy it's it's two different and we
need to recognize
that those are different contexts we
need to recognize that the alliances are
different and the way that we can behave
in society is different if we ever want
to help to transform it and restore a
good culture i'm michael nolis the
michael knowles show i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire
on today's episode the u.s experiences a
record number of illegal border
crossings the biden administration
withdraws one of its vaccine mandates
and controversy erupts over the
australian open's handling of punctuate
protests
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire